this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get five dollars and give all
and also give five dollars to charity do
you want to buy and sell Bitcoin
instantly or get your paycheck deposited
directly right into the app well then
you should definitely get the cash up
it's the best app and the app source the
number one finance app in the App Store
and so you should just like I have
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now here we are after a little
bit of being on the road we are back in
business
overwhelming response from the last
podcast people's people came at babies
help me through this because I was sick
and everyone's like hope you feel better
thank you very much
sometimes we upload these videos on
Tuesday or us sometimes we upload these
podcasts on Tuesdays now did we tweet it
yeah do I say it on the on the podcast
yeah I said all the time sometimes it'll
be open up on Monday something to be up
on Tuesday do people still complain no
yeah they do and that's because
generally people [ __ ] Dom alright
there's a lot him in a black where he
says a person is smart people are dumb
and I always think about that I always
think about that thanks men in black
thanks for always making me think about
that thanks alien movie for making me
always think about that I was in
Cleveland and I liked Cleveland I always
talk about how to people how I like
Cleveland and I didn't I didn't love it
this time because it was snowing and it
was too much there was too much snow I
don't know you know snow is great if
you're like in a beautiful place with
vast open fields or mountains and [ __ ]
like that but if you're in a city and
it's snowing every day
it sucks donkey balls and
so gray and it just sucks and the move
and but the shows were really fun and I
had a good time but let me tell you
about this [ __ ] I went to Boulder
Colorado the next day to do a show for
University Boulder Colorado or whatever
the [ __ ] it's called and it was great
man it was like a thousand still were
like a thousand students went in there
had a good time
students were great and they were really
fun and Thank You Boulder I had a good
time with you guys I think it might have
been the best college show ever um a lot
of comedians don't want to play college
as they say I don't understand that I
think that that's like because they're
worried about like the or they say
college kids get offended like you got
to tell these [ __ ] how to feel
they don't even know how they feel yet
you know so that's why that but that's
why they get offended there because
they're like oh I don't know what I feel
about that situation yet you know the
older you get I think and I'm only 37 so
I'm I'm not but like when you're 90
that's why we 90 year olds don't give a
[ __ ] bro because they just they're too
old I talked about this on stage a
little bit but they're just too old
they don't care when you're when you're
18 anything can offend you when you're
90 nothing offends you cuz eat too old
you're too old to give a [ __ ] hey Sam
but so it was raining it was snowing in
Cleveland and then in Boulder it was
beautiful and then it and then it
[ __ ] and then it and then it and then
it's and then and then in what do you
call it was in LA now it's raining and I
don't want that you know what we talked
about this people who say they love the
rain that's the biggest [ __ ] ever
I'll tell you what though right now on
this podcast I'm having a great time and
more and more people or
are listening to it and I have no
[ __ ] agenda here this is the [ __ ]
fly by the seat of the pants episode man
because I have no notes and I and I
didn't want to do it and that's okay you
got to roll with me man
you got to roll with me how I feel you
can't just be [ __ ] constantly coming
up with like I mean how I hardly come up
with [ __ ] [ __ ] when I do the podcast
anyway I have like three I have like
three or five [ __ ] bullet points and
and I and I don't even know two of them
it'll be like popcorn story and I'll be
like what I'll look at it four days
later let's say popcorn story and I'll
be like when the [ __ ] I haven't eaten
popcorn in nine years did I had this
ex-girlfriend who eats popcorn who ate
popcorn all the time dude she was like
an evil villain where it was like where
was I God that'll be her thing she'll
eat popcorn all the time while she and
it's creepy cuz she's taken over the
world but she's also eating popcorn and
it's kind of friendly hey how good is
popcorn
that's [ __ ] huh who the [ __ ] figured
that out just put in a microwave that
[ __ ] pops put it on a pan and it pops
you put it dude popcorn is so good it's
kind of like the and why don't we only
eat it when we watch movies what's the
deal with that dude if I saw a dude out
in public eating popcorn I would think
he lost his mind but it's so good
that's on me bro that's on me that's how
good it is you should eat it out in
public people eat chips people eat
pretzels
the [ __ ] don't people eat popcorn you
know we'll be the [ __ ] sandwich shops if
they if they give you sandwich
sandwiches and instead of [ __ ] chips
they put a handful of popcorn on there
if they did you'd think they lost our
mind but that's so much better than
chips you know what [ __ ] chips how about
that I'm not talking about tortilla
chips here's the deal here's the deal
tortilla chips good all right if
you [ __ ] double them up though and
you know some Mexican restaurants like
to get real fancy with their tortilla
chips don't if it ain't broke don't fix
it you know what dude and all of a
sudden were in the podcasts I had no
game plan and all of a sudden were
smooth sailing into the podcast we're on
our way up the planes like this and
we're putting our [ __ ] chairs back
and we're relaxing when you put your
chair back by the way right when the
[ __ ] wheels come up because you know
they can't do [ __ ]
cuz you know they can't get up and do
[ __ ] I [ __ ] put it up as we're taking
off and if I can see the [ __ ] person
because you know sometimes they face you
the stewardess or the Stewart they face
you I I look in their eyes as were as
were Drive as we're not at all off yet
and I go and I look in their eyes while
I move back because they can't do [ __ ]
and guess what that three inches of
glorious kickback may give me won't do
[ __ ] if the plane can't do [ __ ] if we're
gonna crash we're gonna crash alright
tortilla chips are good period when
people look in my eyes and tell me that
the dark blue tortilla chips are better
than the beige tortilla chips I want to
[ __ ] piss all over and leave it on my
[ __ ] and thighs when when they're how
about when they're multicolored
multicolored like when they're
multicolored when they bring the [ __ ]
red and blue and like it like we're in a
[ __ ] McDonald's commercial oh [ __ ]
off I want them all beige I'm racist
when it comes to tortilla chips I want a
baby [ __ ] I want them all looking like
Donald Trump that's how I want them I
don't want a red one I don't want a
[ __ ] blue one they're normal and
that's it and when you double them up
dude when you fry them up and they stick
together go [ __ ] yourself
people try to act like ooh I like them
no you don't you like it because you
think you're a bored [ __ ]
that's what it is you know what I get
every time I go to a sandwich shop a
goddamn turkey sandwich that's what I do
that's what I do cuz I know it's what I
like when you're the kind of person I
had another X every time we'd go she
knew what she liked
but she'd look at the menu like it was a
goddamn JK Rowling's book is that who
the author is I always get her mixed up
with JK Simmons hey don't initialize
your [ __ ] goddamn name by the way
what's your name if your name's John
Knowles or whatever the [ __ ] it is that
is John Knowles it's not JK
what's your name just kidding just
kidding Rowling's just kidding Simmons
you know here's the deal you're bored
with your life if you think the [ __ ]
double fried tortilla strips are and
most of the population thinks that the
double fried [ __ ] tortilla you know
what I'm talking about
those oily ones oh but I like this how
about when they [ __ ] give you I go to
this one restaurant place they give you
[ __ ] double they give you a regular
tortilla chips with the guacamole when
they bring the guacamole out they stick
one fancy chip in the [ __ ] guacamole
dude no man oh that drives me nuts and
then people you're with are always like
can we get some of these do you have
these no I want the normal ones we
figured it out dude you know what you
are you're a [ __ ] you know what
go camping go camping if you love those
chips go camping we already figured out
how to do it we already figured out how
to do it go camping why go camping
because we already build these houses
what did we do we lived outside for
[ __ ] thousands and thousands and
thousands of years we lived outside then
we built a Hut figured it out then we
built the [ __ ] how cabin figured it
up there we built the [ __ ] house
figured it out and now we got now we got
toasters now we got microwave now they
got all these [ __ ] we can make
popcorn in a microwave and you want to
go run away from it all and go camping
why we figured out how to live you want
to be near a creek put a goddamn a house
on a creek dude you don't need to be I
need to go out in nature you know what I
just
to get disconnected oh really disconnect
your [ __ ] head from your spinal
column so drastic but serious dude you
don't know how to live life you're bored
and you're boring this is a cult this is
how we live get your cell phone be
surrounded by walls get your cell phone
be surrounded by walls and eat those
goddamn playing tortilla chips and if
you think you're funny
by saying tortilla chips get captured
it's not you're just mispronouncing it
dude
congratulations kachunk step out you
CUDA you're making me upset
that's all good look it's free conch I
want you to do what you want to do it's
free conch
but I got to feel the way I got to feel
about about it I got to feel the way I
got to feel about it God you know what's
good at brownie you know what's bad you
know it's good a brownie you know it's
good ice cream when I get a brownie
without dude I [ __ ] everybody up man
when I get a brownie
I get the brownie and they're like you
want ice cream on it no I don't want the
[ __ ] ice cream on it I want the ice
cream on the side and I want the brownie
on the [ __ ] other side okay if it's
touching I'm out if it's touching of
nothing I want to [ __ ] put the equal
ratio that I want of the [ __ ] brownie
in with the that that's what I want and
don't heat the brownie up to ha much do
not heat the Bernie up too much because
then [ __ ] belt dude this is so simple
I want to run for president and this is
this [ __ ] I want to talk about [ __ ] all
the politics everyone's crooked anyway
I'm gonna talk about brownie we need to
increase brownie and ice cream
spending the superimpose chart over my
face dipping in the polls we need to get
back to our beige one single tortilla
chips we need to get back to it
Paul negative polls but president what
do you feel about the racial tension in
a but we need
speaking of racial tension we need only
base purtiest strips boo boo
that reminds me but what do you think
about government spending on I think
equally parts distributed of ice cream
and also brownies separate plates boo we
don't wear long sleeve shirts with
shorts blue are you
yeah man popcorns this [ __ ]
period but when you get what's what's
harder what's harder though Oh goddamn
it I'll stop coughing what's harder
working out doing plyometrics or trying
to get a piece of popcorn out of the
back your teeth what's harder what's
harder how much of a little we tweak
[ __ ] ass do you feel like when you're
when you're when you realize your tongue
is out of shape and you're just and it's
liking like and it looks like you're
morphing into an alien you're just you
ever try to do the relaxed thing though
you ever [ __ ] trying you're trying to
get that [ __ ] thing out of your teeth
so hard and you're going overboard
overboard up overboard and then you
realize okay you know what dude okay and
in your head you having this
conversation like just relax relax relax
let's try to finesse it out do you ever
do that cuz that works do you ever do
that one no see that's why he would have
stuff stuck in his teeth and I wouldn't
and you're [ __ ] and you just
sometimes relax and you just touch it
you just used the tongue to touch the
little kernel and then it [ __ ] plops
on out dude
sometimes it's about relaxing I've never
talked about more more [ __ ] that doesn't
matter than I have on this podcast right
now this episode but I in a way it all
come dude you know what happened I
no when I realized that this is a real
cult for real in Cleveland somebody came
up to me and said hey man I just want to
let you know I'm a little bit CUDA
because of this thing that I did and I
said it's okay we all are we all are
it's a cult
it's okay we all are we all we all we
all are a little bit CUDA I said to him
like I would like he was coming to me we
are all a little bit CUDA it's about
[ __ ] diminishing the kunais and
fighting it that's what it's about
you're a real baby though man if you're
thinking about it you are a real baby I
met some elders too at the [ __ ] at
the Cleveland hilarities Cleveland
[Music]
anyway well I don't what was I talking
about [ __ ] popcorn before that [ __ ]
doesn't matter it doesn't matter Juan
fires probably looking a [ __ ]
interracial porn you know it's a fun
thing to do is anytime you see somebody
on a laptop in public imagine them
watching interracial porn one time I was
at a coffee shop and this guy was
watching porn and then the guy at a
coffee shop said hey man do you know if
that guy's watchin porn or not and I was
like what the one of the workers it was
like yeah we had some complaints imagine
the [ __ ] level of boss you gotta be
to go set up in a public coffee shop
open it up and then [ __ ] press play
and just oh yeah yeah the swallow that
[ __ ] is the most [ __ ] turned on you
can ever be oh yeah that nah haha oh man
that's funny that's funny
for [ __ ] sake you know anyway I
appreciate you guys listening dude the
podcast is actually growing its is
growing I don't have
you know and I'm thinking about having
guests every now and then just because
it keeps it interesting and I think
it'll help the podcast grow but also
maybe I won't do it because this is for
sure a rant like imagine if I try to run
for president how much they take off of
this [ __ ] podcast and they'd be like
like I've said I've said everything on
this vibe already like you know what one
quote that always haunts me is you've
already done the thing that ruins you
you will you've already done the thing
that's going to ruin you oh that's so
[ __ ] crazy that's some [ __ ] like
that's probably like house of cards or
something how about how dramatic
they make these TV shows did you see the
[ __ ] thing about on house of cards
where it was like done done done and
then it shows the lady and she's like
we're just getting started dude how come
every every show is just getting started
why do they have to say that why dude
there could be like [ __ ] eleven
seasons in and it's like and we're just
getting started and then get cancelled
the next day you're not tricking me dude
and we're just getting started
oh really yeah you're ninety we're just
getting started you literally just fired
the lead solver we're just getting
started I'm gonna say that I'm gonna say
that after I have sex after I have an
orgasm and then I roll over I'm gonna
say sweetheart we're just getting
started
[Music]
wake up sorry what you just said we're
just getting started
oh no no I know but sorry I got Simon I
meant about the sleeping thing we're
just getting started like don't even
finish it so disrespectful how fast by
the way can you fall asleep after sex me
14 seconds 14 [ __ ] seconds I go haha
have you ever fell asleep during sex i
straight-up have like that's so how I
did it with a girlfriend once and it was
like she was like hey and I was like
what's up she was like uh how's that
supposed to make me feel I was like uh I
was amazing
I get so tired I had won one of my my ex
that loves popcorn would try and keep me
up cuz I talk I talk so much when I'm
tired and I'm falling asleep and I'll
just start talking I remember one time
she recorded me and I was talking about
alligators and [ __ ] and how much they
were like how much they were demons I
mean we've talked about on parkas but I
didn't know what I was saying really
and then she played it for me the next
day and I was like oh my god I was
talking about alligators and how they
were [ __ ] [ __ ] asses and how they
ain't [ __ ] but they were demons but like
I would and I was awake dude cuz like
because she was talking to me and I
don't really remember it look at this
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] I saw this
earlier
I hate [ __ ] like this click it the whole
thing women who need a margarita a
million dollars and a nap what [ __ ]
person would tag him tag the women this
is the [ __ ] also why is it just for
women I'll be good no matter what you
got in your downstairs area and look at
this look at this look at this look at
this thing on Facebook women who need a
million a margarita a million dollars in
an app and then just names under it
Jessica Janet Meghan Kathy Britney Kayla
Erica
Carolyn Melissa imagine Stefanie imagine
being Stephanie and being like oh that's
so true about me now [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
also imagine be Stephanie with a why and
it only says Stephanie with an IE and
you're like oh man
I hate the internet but also it's the
greatest I love the Internet
it's just like did is make this [ __ ]
oh man you got to see what the [ __ ] want
fire is doing with the [ __ ] screen
right now how about did you see about
the interview about Michael Caine about
how he wouldn't work with Woody Allen
anymore
along they asked him Michael Caine would
you work with the Woody Allen anymore
I love the why because they use didn't
he like [ __ ] his daughter or some [ __ ]
what do you [ __ ] Woody Allen Judy [ __ ]
who'd he have sex with his daughter I'm
so stoned actor Michael Caine who won an
Academy Award in 1987 for Allen's film
Hannah and her sister said during the
interview with The Guardian he continued
alma patron of the NSPCC and that very
strong views about pedophilia really
what are they a wouldn't know it because
why because I've got strong feelings
against it alright cool man Peter
arse guard says he won't work with Woody
Allen again but Jeff Daniels remains
undecided cool just do every actor in
Hollywood you know I want somebody I
want to get Fame enough so I want to get
famous enough so people ask me [ __ ] like
that and then I go like this hey Chris
Lee Chris Lee over here would you ever
work with Woody Allen my god Nance for
you gotta go and then do like a cartoon
like this and then look at them for a
little bit and then just move my arms
the other way go and then just walk away
and then when I arrive to my next
destination go car car car car car car
no matter how long it takes even if I
Drive there hey Chris D'Elia Chris Chris
can we get a question hey Chris would
you ever work with Woody Allen mmm
interesting you ask that question gotta
go kill and then just walk away and then
they just watch me walk away a little
bit and not even go fast just disrespect
the people you know disrespecting the
p.m. um well we're getting off the rails
today bro but this is how we do it man
some days we just are loosey-goosey I'm
down for a silly goose time and that's
it man when people talk politics and you
get boring as [ __ ] for too long I'm out
I'm out dude hit the ejector button I am
I am pew
I am [ __ ] out dude um
okay let's do this hear me on DS you've
heard me talk about me on DS and you
know that I'm a big believer in their
product they're the perfect balance of
comfortable fit every month they have a
new and exciting print or they have
multiple new and exciting prints and
they arrive at your door and a fun bag I
love me on these it's the only
underwears I wear now I said you're the
only underwear I wear now that doesn't
mean I am a Russian who knows English
now even though I say you're the only
the only underwear but me me undies uses
a lens aghhhh micro modal in their
underwear
it's sustainably sourced naturally soft
fiber that starts with Beachwood trees
and ends with the most amazing fabric
you've ever experienced I'm telling you
if you never put these on you got it
feels really good and it keeps you
relaxed and keeps you less stressed I
love me on these at work they I wear
them all the that's all I wear 100%
satisfaction guarantee me and these
guarantees you'll love their undies
where you get your money back
hmm adventurous prints and designed
designs are all limited edition so you
get cool ones that other people don't
have you don't see them too much beyond
this has a great offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchasers when you
purchase any me andis you get 20% off
and free shipping me undies is so sure
you'll love their underwear that they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee you
don't love your first pair you get a
full refund
no-brainer get 20% off a pair with the
most comfortable undies you will ever
put on okay your 20% off your first pair
of free shipping a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to my undies comm /
Congrats that's me Indies comm /
Congrats square cash if you haven't
heard we're switching to the cash app
now I've already done it when I say we I
mean all of us that are going to the log
cabin it's the simplest way to pay
people back friends family very
thoughtful wedding guests anyone really
you pay back Michael Caine with it and
he can pay back you but yo can you pay
me back my with the square cash and it
goes like this I love it and then it
goes fast and free at most payments
probably the one by Michael Caine can be
deposited directly to your bank account
in just a few seconds did you know the
cash out also lets you do may way more
than that now you can even buy and sell
Bitcoin instantly get your paycheck
deposited right to the app pull money
out of the ATM with the free custom cash
card
or use it to spend anywhere you like you
really won't find a more useful finance
app out there it's the only one I use
for now and of course you when you
download the freak the cash app five
dollars goes to you and five dollars
goes to time's up Legal Defense Fund I
think that's a good fun that's why we're
getting behind it here our
congratulations the podcast so download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
it's pretty cool how one fire made the
the things double-sided which I don't
like because I like to read the [ __ ] and
I like to toss it out now I know it's
worse for trees but let's face it I'll
be dead long and gone before that
matters in the environment and that's
how we all feel
Delaine then they Ning Hey Dude how
about people who are trying to make the
planet good for other generations dude
alright go ahead
I'll help a little bit will I go out of
my way huh I'll recycle will I go out of
my way hey I want to make [ __ ] tough for
my kids [ __ ] that I want to make [ __ ]
tough for my kids no why
need something to do denlon then then
then so disrespectful
I want to make [ __ ] tougher everyone's
trying to make sure easier for the
generations and [ __ ] [ __ ] that dude
how about no you know what actually I
disagree with that I'm just obviously
playing around but how about when I
heard that Bill Gates was only gonna
leave ten million dollars for his kids
hey man what you doing everything for
that she doing hey dude chu doing what
are you doing
you leave ten million dollar I know
that's more than enough but also leave
billions hey man
you netted in a girl and had offspring
leaving billions hey dude you got all up
in them guts and only gonna leave them a
small percentage of your fortune you bad
purse you bad planner hey dude nut nur
nine months later give billions give
them billions dude and then have them
just go shopping on a montage what I
won't to cut and it might be hard to
handle by in Tesla's and [ __ ] people
like a flame
mom's and candle I'll take one he points
to an Asian woo
sign me up for everything at the
magazine rack dinner tips come true go
walking into [ __ ] Club Monaco I'll
take one of every sides whoo-hoo goes to
Club Monaco who the [ __ ] goes to Club
goddamn Monaco who wears a short sleep
[ __ ] button-down pink shirt with
khakis you know that's the rapists
attire
that's the date rapist attire if you
have pink anywhere on you I feel like
you you date rape as a guy and I wear
pink but I don't do that but I just you
don't know you know what the date rape
is attire is those [ __ ] what is that
carnation pink shorts what are those
carnation pink shorts where you look
like your dad's a lawyer and can get you
off what are they called
what are those called are they Bermuda
shorts I feel like you date rape if you
have if you wear those what what what
are the but with those though what are
they called those [ __ ] salmon ones
she's what I'm talking about if you wear
that you [ __ ] of date rape those
short ones where your ass is good in it
if your ass is good in it to [ __ ] off
look at those stupid with a braided belt
holy [ __ ] I'll high kick you if you have
a braided belt and those [ __ ]
carnation pink shorts i'll high kick you
of course you can get him Bloomingdale's
if you walk into bloom he doesn't you'd
be like hey where's the rape attire
they'll be like ah here over this way
and let's show you the carnation pink
[ __ ] shorts your dad's a lawyer right
you get a 10% off who goes to Club
Monaco who shops there I Club Monaco who
do they who is even for they have the
most regular ass clothes that try to
think that they're like a little bit
stylish but also you know what they are
you know what they [ __ ] are they're
the [ __ ] blue tortilla trip strips
that's what they are through the
tortilla strips Club Monaco of clothing
go [ __ ] yourself man
go [ __ ] yourself give me a white t-shirt
playing tortilla strip or give me the
whole [ __ ] enchilada give me the
whole enchilada and let me wear a
[ __ ] green leather jacket but Club
Monaco with your regular ass blue shirt
go [ __ ] yourself
trying to be a little bit stylish with
some [ __ ] stripes on it eat my [ __ ]
straight up dude eat my male [ __ ] dude
hey Club Monaco eat my male [ __ ] with
those [ __ ] lows
how about you know what pisses me the
[ __ ] off is when dope clothing companies
like Club Monaco or whatever the [ __ ]
also makes Hughes leave the shoes to the
[ __ ] shoe company dude if you're a
[ __ ] if you make clothes and you make
pants and shirts and you make shoes eat
my mail [ __ ] do it and how about the
website on a club on Club Monaco it says
enjoy 15% off I'll be the judge of
[ __ ] what I enjoy you give me the 15%
off all judge if I like it or not has
that that's like when they say thank you
on the trash can I didn't do it yet I'm
just looking at it from across the room
thanks for what eat my mail [ __ ] dude
you can't thank me for doing some [ __ ] I
didn't do you hey thank you for throwing
away your really guess what I'm doing
putting it on the grass dude I'll never
you already did the thing that buried
you
you already think did the thing that
ruined you and I'm pretty sure for me
it's this episode of this podcast v
enjoy 15% off I'm going to Club Monaco
right after this and I'm walking up to
the [ __ ] guy I'm asking for their
manager and I'm gonna tell him look I'm
right in the eye and I'm gonna say hey
man I'll be I'll be the judge of what
the [ __ ] I enjoy you don't tell me what
I enjoy and I'll say what do you mean
and I'll say you know what the [ __ ] I
mean and get rid of these rapists shorts
then I go
[Music]
that's me driving away or when they will
have the sign that's a smile you're on
camera
I give the finger I find the camera I
give the finger and I do it with a
straight flight straight face straight
face or straight face mmm angry yeah cuz
I said flase do I [ __ ] up my words a lot
yeah is it cuz I think too fast I don't
wanna get the words yes that doesn't
make me angry ya know is that God's
fault yes you know where there's no God
cuz people stutter that's why hey God
don't make us stutter make us rip roarin
everything we need to say [ __ ] die
get it dang it dang it dang it dang it
make it [ __ ] dang it dang it that's
you know there's no God cause it's
stuttering why would God make us stutter
why cuz it's up to us cuz free will
really eat my [ __ ] eat my back [ __ ]
excuse me while I turn round eat my back
[ __ ] that's code for [ __ ] YUM eat my
back [ __ ] YUM
I would really like to eat some back
[ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] off
the rails
you know what you elk you elk I'll
[ __ ] quit this goddamn cut podcast you
[ __ ] tell a friend about this [ __ ] or
I'll quit this [ __ ] thing mail it to
one of your friends dude mail it to one
of your friends um you know what I'm
doing right now I'm so disrespectful I'm
ordering post mates right now on your
mother [ __ ] that's what I'm doing
we're chilling we're hanging and I'm
[ __ ] order and post mates right now
on your mother [ __ ] like I'm riding
on your mother [ __ ]
where is it oh no post mates right now
BAM
doing it during the podcast so
disrespectful now don't give a [ __ ] dude
I'm ordering from this place called
beefsteak and I'm getting a whole
Jockamo Lebo dude right there just got
it [ __ ] yeah dude here it comes
it'll be here before the podcast is over
and I'll stop it early I'm disrespecting
you and your family you [ __ ]
when it gets here it goes ding dong
podcast over no no no man I'm [ __ ]
sitting there with the real YUM oh wait
what's that [ __ ] roll up sometimes I see
[ __ ] wan fire is on get your wands ready
first trailer for fantastic beast sequel
is here why can't we just watch a movie
why guys say [ __ ] like get your wands
ready how do you get my wand
press play you're not a magician you
work at a bank I want a divorce
that's how that conversation goes it's
just unbelievable man the [ __ ] that we
think we are because of the internet
remember when the internet didn't exist
I do I remember when I was 9 and the
internet didn't exist and and we knew we
weren't [ __ ] we knew we weren't [ __ ] we
knew if we had an idea there was nowhere
to put it that idea died and then 90
year olds who died in 1989 all your
ideas died with you but now everyone
thinks they're [ __ ] important because
they have a phone that's why when you
talk [ __ ] to me I retweet it you've
entered the Octagon congratulations
delete your tweet after that you [ __ ]
[ __ ] how about I take issue with the
tweet out there this week so John Mayer
tweeted a thing that I liked and it got
like 400 million retweets it said
something like
the only way the only way to be
beautiful is to be kind or something
otherwise it's just congratulations on
your face that's cool cute little way to
say it nice and then James Blunt who
burns people here is it here's what John
Mayer said go go up scroll if you're
pretty you're pretty but the only way to
be beautiful is to be loving otherwise
it's just congratulations about your
face great cool and then James Blunt
came out of the woodwork and rights mate
I've covered this already and everyone's
like oh you burned him no he didn't
that's what every song is about that's
what every song is about is being
beautiful on the inside
James Blunt wasn't the first guy to make
that [ __ ] song some guy named like
[ __ ] Lord something the six made a
[ __ ] song like that back in 1200 it's
not epic everyone arts epic everyone
[ __ ] says that but John Mayer had a
good way to say it you said it the way
John Mayer said it no you said you're
beautiful you're beautiful you're
beautiful ass true but I'm in a subway
and I saw your face and now I'm going
away I'm gonna slip we're going
somewhere and you already made the stop
or whatever John Mayer said it a good
way James once sang it a different way
don't say you covered it already cuz
everyone covered it already that's like
saying oh I [ __ ] wore a shirt a virus
earned I have I reserved a bar chart
that's true you think you wear shirt too
and you think you're the guy who wears a
shirt but I was the guy who wore the
sound first as the guy wore the shirt
alright how about one singing when they
get real crisp when they're just like we
get real quiet and crispin crispy
um I just I don't know I don't know what
do you guys want to talk about now dude
I want to do some Twitter questions or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah let's do some
Twitter Oh or let's look at the oh I
think I had a most Instagram [ __ ] up
of the week
let me look I don't know what it is so
don't know how to say to somebody when I
look at my uh goddamn look his stupid
[ __ ] oh oh here's one she didn't want to
be loved she wanted to be loved she
didn't want to love she wanted to be
loved and that was entirely different
and then a picture of this chick and her
nipples are erect say yeah hey we'll do
a catch you later okay um here we go
okay oh wait did I already do this one I
think I did this one already damn it the
[ __ ] people dude already did the eyes
one I opened up my gifts the eyes I
don't know maybe we won't do it here let
me just do this one I'll fire one I'm
alright guys it's time for the most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the week
here we go
for Monday patience sure is key
patience is everything we all eventually
end up where we need to be in life yeah
tell that to somebody who [ __ ] can't
feel their legs will all eventually end
up where we need to be in life with who
were meant to be with yeah tell that to
someone who's [ __ ] dying of cancer
alone prematurely and their wife left
them and doing what we should be doing
oh yeah tell that to somebody who
[ __ ] still has to work in his ninety
years old it had to make ends meet it's
only a matter of time really everyone
[ __ ] dies have patience my oh wow
have patience my friends fr a and end to
end es happy Monday happy Monday sending
positive vibes your way all day every
day see ya let's do a [ __ ] large SIA
have you ever got to see it enlarge
excuse me do you guys have see his
enlarged
we got extra large for you oh here's
another one this was a totally
unintentional photo I took of myself oh
this guy's looking at the camera -
selfie one of the first ones I ever took
with my new camera Thanks and then
thanks the person who got it for him I
guess it's kind of metaphorical though
I'm in the captain's chair the driver's
seat I can set the destination for my
journey and not just this small journey
from one location to another I'm the
captain of my life I mean this guy well
first of all definitely an only child
I'm the captain of my life and I can set
my destination only a white guy would
write this [ __ ]
there's backseat drivers yes but with
practice and determination I'm learning
how to shut those voices out Oh what
about if they're telling you to [ __ ]
you're gonna hit something even my own
voice sometimes and you crazy
that's cool craze that voice can be the
harshest but I can't let that weigh me
down good vibes only am i right
hey how about this you think your voice
inside your head is the harshest what
about this one mine go [ __ ] yourself
that's harsh say yeah you don't matter
hmm
we'll do a catch you later I can't wait
to the [ __ ] postmates scum all right
let's do instead let's do our Twitter
questions are you up are we up didn't we
do that one is that last week as a
coffee lover what do you think of you
okay oh yeah that's right that's right
last last one we had people who eat
there eat at fast-food restaurant and
then this one is by Molly Belcher at
Molly Belcher one keepin it real as a
coffee lover what do you think of people
who go to fast food restaurants to order
coffee well I mean you know coffee is
everywhere you can get it anywhere
it's like water kind of you know you
have like every place sells water like
even like Radio Shack sells bottles of
water but like as a coffee lover if
you're going to a fast-food restaurant
to get the coffee just to get the coffee
that's weird you should go to a coffee
spot but you know people always talk
about how McDonald's has good coffee and
[ __ ] and Dunkin Donuts has good coffee
Duncan's on his ice ice coffee Dunkin
Donuts ice coffee tastes like a [ __ ]
like tastes like it's terrible but I
guess the regular coffee is good I've
never had it there I am McDonald's ice
flavored coffee is good but if you get
in flavor coffee what are you doing
drink [ __ ] regular coffee yeah when
you get I'd I want to fight that person
change that I don't even care about that
one um no not that one now
uh okay here we go
Emily Pope at poppycock 57 change it
forgot about the band crystally I put on
Wendy's and I ate it and now I have food
poisoning this will teach me to disobey
you know what yeah don't eat it don't
eat it because it's poison not because I
didn't say this is [ __ ] McDonald's
how about McDonald's that put the
[ __ ] upside-down arches for
International Women's Day yo [ __ ] you
McDonald's you give people including
women cancer go [ __ ] yourself
oh really you put an upside-down W so
you'd get the good PR go [ __ ] yourself
you literally kill women these [ __ ]
backwards ask [ __ ] Oh
International Women's Day upside down W
shut up what are you doing for women
you're killing them and the men say yeah
dude that's the that's that's that's so
stupid
you [ __ ] dumb shits oh oh you got a
salad choice
Oh McDonald's you got a salad choice I
[ __ ] eat my dick these [ __ ]
fast-food places here at [ __ ] Wendy's
we've we will give you a carcinogen what
did it call it carcinogenic whatever I'm
an idiot
so these things from everybody was
posting about International Women's Day
you know [ __ ] that abuse women
post about it even you know I tell you
man
if you have your own day you're you're
you're you're you're making you're my
minority or whatever the [ __ ] you're
you're making it you're its own thing
it'll always be that you need to we need
to celebrate everybody all the time
together you can't have somebody have a
day because they
you're saying you don't matter as much
you're literally saying you don't matter
as much
hey it's [ __ ] if I said hey it's
[ __ ] white guys with long hair day I
don't want I don't want my own day I
want to be equal as everyone else and
have every day just like everyone else
has if you have your own day and you're
a minority or whatever the [ __ ] you're
saying yourself you know I get it you
get a time to [ __ ] celebrate the the
compliment accomplishments of it
whatever but people take it out of
context and then they make it they make
it what's that word secular no how do I
what's the word is it secular secular
secular meaning no that's not the
[ __ ] thing and now I'm a [ __ ]
idiot a noun pissed I know you're not a
sports fan but can you pick a college
basketball team for the true babies to
get behind I'll tell you what no this is
from Matt [ __ ] tone hey shits in your
name dude hey man just because you put a
C in there [ __ ] we still know it's [ __ ]
you put an extra T on there again the
name [ __ ] yeah
um no I don't even know who is on it I
don't even know what games
Albarn is somebody saying March Madness
it's not that mad just guys playing with
a ball I don't know who's in it I won't
pick a team see ya guys running around
playing playing the thing not even
getting paid for it you're in college
it's fun cool do it yourself not
watching you getting paid maybe I'll
watch money's on the line cool if not
don't give a [ __ ]
people love college sports that's the
saddest thing in the world that's the
saddest thing in the world if you like
college sports because you went to that
college congratulations you're sad get
behind the [ __ ] Knicks [ __ ] get
behind the [ __ ]
Wizards get a real team dude oh you're
[ __ ] rootin for the Sooners you're sad
cuz you went to Oklahoma or whatever the
[ __ ] what you major in huh
sociology did you pick up a ball no were
you even part of the team no guess what
if you were sadder you don't play
anymore
see ya turn the TV off if the Sooners
are playing turn it on if the goddamn
Knicks are playing turn it on if the
[ __ ] Orlando Magic is playing or the
Miami Heat
if they're not playing and they're not
the Timberwolves turn it off and don't
root for a [ __ ] college team because
you were in the same College 40 years
ago and they got a fat gut drinking beer
from a koozie you said Bryan Callen left
me a voicemail I'm sure it talks copious
amounts of [ __ ] and the transcript is
not available here's a deal iPhone if
you're gonna make it so the transcript
is available make it so all the
transcripts are available if you can't
do it with the technology don't let it
happen you remember that thing louis c.k
went on board went on Conan with and he
was talking about how everything is
amazing and just because you can't check
your [ __ ] Wi-Fi up on the airplane
that you're a piece of [ __ ] you see that
you know what I completely disagree with
that completely [ __ ] disagree with
that if you make the thing make it work
if you can't make it work all the time
don't make the thing I mean it I mean it
if you can't make what Airport Wi-Fi
dude you never [ __ ] work you never
work therefore don't have Airport Wi-Fi
I don't want the frustration of does it
work in this [ __ ] terminal naturally
it doesn't work at the Delta term and
I'll really take it off for [ __ ]
everyone
take it off for everyone don't make
something kind of work it you know um I
don't know I'm getting heated baby well
let's see what the food is it's coming
but how about you got that might be
handled [ __ ] bill gates's son or
daughter just like I want that one
pointing to a minority I'd like to I'd
like to purchase him you can't do that I
have billions what about like flame
burns a candle
Halla notes dude they were they [ __ ]
every song Sarah if my mom heard that
right now she'd be like I wish you words
I wish you saying what else we got
thoughts on dr. Phil le mythical Gabby
whoa you know what I shouldn't even
respond to your [ __ ] thing
your name's Ellie on the thing and at
mythical Gabby change it yesterday
thoughts on dr. Phil well III I'll watch
dr. Phil and laughs my [ __ ] goddamn
ass off that guy that guy isn't there
was one
time I was on the road I was on the road
coming back from Las Vegas one fire were
you there I don't think you're worried
it was me
[ __ ] Chris my brother and Ashton
that's who it was
and I was making fun of dr. Phil and I
was I was doing this [ __ ] stupid joke
where where dr. Phil was interviewing
all of our friends and I would say like
and I would make fun of like I would do
the intro I would be like now you have a
big head like one of our friends had a
big head
I'd be like now you have a big head so
what do you do in the morning when you
get out of the bed does it ever take
over and you lose your balance and can't
catch up to yourself and then fall
directly into the wall like I would do
that and your hair is too red so what's
the deal with your big head and your
hair is T red and they were laughing saw
it it was the hardest I ever saw two of
my friends laugh they were they were
laughing so [ __ ] hard and I mean I
mean I did one of them was just like
like and and and they were crying and
tears were shooting out of their face
and and and then I got what the one
thing that made my buddy Chris laugh so
hard is because I started getting it so
much more and more ridiculous that he
was saying the most ridiculous [ __ ] and
for some reason I made I was interim
people and I was he was doctor if it was
losing his mind as he was in throwing
the people and I said my next guest is
an Excalibur weapon and dude he [ __ ]
he cried he was he is the [ __ ] that was
coming out of his face was like and it
was so funny that he was having that we
were started laughing more and and and
now we still say Excalibur weapon
my next guest is an Excalibur weapon
please welcome Jordan look everyone says
a yay
dude he could say anything oh [ __ ]
oh we were crying do it on the way back
from Las Vegas and everything is funny
or - when you're when you've been
somewhere for too long you know like we
were in the car for five hours just
sweating in some [ __ ] Mercury Sable
you know it was like some maroon Mercury
Sable that my buddy used to drive and he
wasn't even driving it was my other
buddy was driving cuz he didn't want to
drive that's so Las Vegas but I like I
like dr. Phil cause he's [ __ ]
hilarious like that my next guest is an
Excalibur weapon
give it up and everyone was just happy
about it we taken over one city at a
time I think we're about to wrap [ __ ] up
man oh wait we have oh wait hold on
silly me we've got an elder
Oh this was the [ __ ] one that I
showed you guys all right cool
this that had to be an elder when we
passed this around with the with one
fire and my other text chain and my pipe
said my dad played it and he was crying
laughing with my mom
Richie pallies at Richie Polly's for the
CUDA song he made the CUDA song which is
[ __ ] hilarious
Richie we're gonna DM you with the with
the with the details it's so it's so
funny man this [ __ ] thing I was
crying laughing I mean do we have it or
we will play it next time we'll play it
next time for you guys a little bit of
it it's a long it's a long song but dude
it's so funny this guy like wrote and
composed the real [ __ ] coot actually
you know what I bet I could [ __ ] CUDA
google it the song
uh here comes uh no no no here comes the
[ __ ] thing like an Americana [ __ ]
song about a barracuda the car you know
anyway we'll play next time but it was
so funny or look it up I tweeted it or
look at it it's a Ritchie plays Ritchie
palace pallies pallies alright alright
Square cash have you switched yet
download the free square cash app and
two rewards code congrats get five
dollars give five dollars - times up get
it for iOS or Android now follow the
leader tour
you could buy tickets or crystally accom
next week I'm announcing the second leg
of the tour got some dates coming in
they're coming up they're like like New
Jersey and [ __ ] like that I think
Delaware anyway right now on sale
Tallahassee Orlando Charleston there's
the second show added Pittsburgh Dayton
Huntsville AL Alabama Alabama hospital
Huntsville Alabama
Nashville Tennessee Denver Colorado
Adelaide show Boise Idaho added a Late
Show Cleveland's / Cleveland still on
here because of one fire and obviously
naturally one fire we got the restock up
is it up no not not up one fire they're
ours
what yeah I know but you also put
Cleveland here so maybe it's ready this
is an old copy on fire subscribe to the
YouTube channel you guys our numbers are
doing well tell your friend about this
if you don't
is there someone close to you dude that
doesn't know about this podcast why the
[ __ ] wouldn't you show it you're not
doing your job as a [ __ ] baby I mean
you're trying to get to the lockout and
we try to get this log cabin or what
download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS or
Android subscribe rate and review if you
haven't done any of this [ __ ] yet you
know look the [ __ ] if you haven't done
any of this [ __ ] yet then what the
[ __ ] going on here you just listening
willy-nilly this is real [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
video episodes go up Tuesday's or
Wednesdays are you somebody who says oh
how come the video episodes come up
later than then what the [ __ ] are you
doing dude
deal with it man man I'm firing
corrigible white male black commie you
could watch that ship find it I was on
the good doctor last night if you saw it
Thanks
[Music]